nothing else to report Ed as we've been
banned from the press gaggle and labeled
as fake news by the president
we'll have to prove them wrong thanks Tim
Trump's approval numbers have
gone to new lows according to a new poll
and we're never wrong about those
and is starbucks new cup bringing people to tears
no, but we'll find two tweets like we do every year
Uh Ed? Yes Tim?
Look this is obviously bad but do you think
you could maybe help our case a tad
they say we're not news that we just make stuff up
my apologies Tim I'll fix that right up
a nurse shark with a man in Florida park
could this summer be
the summer of sharks
plus a product you own causes death exponentially
the answer to that misleading question eventually
Ed you're hiding the cause of acute meningitis
do you see why perhaps
there are  folks who don't like us
I really believe that they're flatly just wrong
but can you just help me a little
Can do Cap-i-tan.
well a hero is born meet the daring A.G.
won't enforce laws with which she
disagrees plus
Kim Davis the mouth breathing slob
should we Jail public servants who won't do their job
okay, see that's what I mean
that's what they accuse
that we color the coverage to match with
our views should we not be objective and
foster a trust
I suppose you're right Tim
I'll do what I must all world on the brink
perils unfurled as Trump speaks
with the most dangerous man in the world
plus Mitt Romney's gaffes just don't seem to slow
his moronic claim Russians is our biggest foe
Ed and finally it's given all
journalists stupors but proof has been found
by Pricewaterhouse Coopers the
president making with great genuflection
concessions to Russia if he wins the election
a white house in chaos we'll give you a peek
at the transcripts we got from a delightful new leak
Plus Edward Snowden, the traitor abroad
Should leakers be hung
like the cowards they are?